En un video anterior hablamos sobre la
cromatografía de capa fina, y esta es la
técnica que se utiliza para saber cuántas cosas
tenemos en una muestra, o tal vez podemos decir
para saber las propiedades relativas o la
polaridad relativa de las cosas que hay en
una muestra. En este tipo de cromatografía lo que
hacemos es poner una muestra, normalmente en un
gel de sílice al que llamamos fase estacionaria,
y después ponemos una fase móvil por aquí abajo,
que en este caso deberá ser menos polar y luego
se moverá hacia arriba por el gel de sílice,
y mientras lo hace, como podemos imaginar,
va a interactuar con la muestra original,
y por lo tanto, partes de la muestra original se
moverán hacia arriba con la fase móvil, y partes
diferentes se sentirán atraídas por esa fase móvil
y no atraídas por el gel de sílice en diferentes
grados. Podemos imaginar que si existe una parte
en tu muestra original que es más polar, entonces
será más difícil de mover, porque se va a sentir
atraída a la fase estacionaria y menos atraída a
la fase móvil, y entonces se moverá menos. Así
que esta será la parte más polar de tu muestra
a medida que avanza desde su ubicación original,
y la parte menos polar de tu muestra, bueno, no
se sentirá tan atraída por la fase estacionaria y
será más disoluble en la fase móvil menos polar y,
por lo tanto, llegará más lejos. Esta será la
parte menos polar de tu muestra original. Con
esto podemos ver la separación y podríamos aportar
otras ideas sobre las que hablamos en ese otro
video. En este video quiero presentar una idea
muy muy, muy, muy similar, sólo que las cosas se
mueven en una dirección distinta, es la noción
de cromatografía en columna. Ahora bien, en la
cromatografía en columna, de igual forma que en
la cromatografía de capa fina, tenemos algún tipo
de vial o algún tipo de columna, podemos decir,
y normalmente tiene una pequeña llave por aquí
abajo, porque queremos observar lo que sale por
la parte inferior. Y lo que hacemos es llenarlo
con la fase estacionaria que, una vez más, es
frecuentemente gel de sílice, y este va a ser
muy polar. No tiene que ser gel de sílice pero es
lo más común. Después ponemos en la parte superior
algo de la muestra y después tenemos alguna fase
móvil, el solvente que vamos a poner encima de la
muestra. Vamos a hacer algo como esto, y ¿qué
crees que vaya a suceder? Bueno, tu fase móvil
comenzará a moverse hacia abajo, a través de
la fase estacionaria, y va a interactuar con la
muestra. Ahora bien, ¿qué es lo que pasará con los
componentes más polares de tu muestra? Bueno, los
componentes más polares de tu muestra se sentirán
más atraídos por la fase estacionaria y menos
atraídos por la fase móvil, por lo que se moverán
menos. Entonces las partes más polares de tu
muestra tal vez sólo lleguen hasta aquí, mientras
que las partes menos polares de tu muestra tendrán
menor atracción por la fase estacionaria y se
moverán más con la fase móvil, por lo que es
posible que se muevan hasta acá abajo. Entonces,
la gran conclusión es que la diferencia entre
las dos cromatografías es sólo la dirección en la
que se mueve. En la cromatografía de capa fina la
parte más polar es el punto inferior, mientras que
en la cromatografía de columna la parte más polar
es la capa superior, justo aquí, es decir, esta
área púrpura; y por supuesto todo esto depende
de la polaridad de la fase estacionaria
y la polaridad relativa de la fase móvil.
Pero lo que acabo de mostrar es una situación
típica, por lo tanto, cuando estés trabajando
con cromatografía de capa fina o con cromatografía
de columna debes prestar atención a la dirección.